it's you know it's difficult to
determine exactly what the number is
because the government kept shifting the
number but it's basically the FBI at one
point had said that the mortgage company
I owned had done like 40 million in
mortgage fraud but keep in mind too that
that's it's misleading because if you
have a hundred thousand dollar loan one
hundred thousand dollar loan on a piece
of property that you bought for a
hundred and ten thousand dollars there's
no real dollar loss so they're counting
that is a hundred thousand dollars in
fraud well I didn't get any of that so
the mortgage company they're saying they
were saying at one point they were
threatening that they were in charge of
me forty million and mortgage fraud on
the for the the mortgage company that I
owned and then and there's multiple
frauds so it really the numbers really
that I'd always kind of heard was
fifteen million but eleven and a half 12
has I've heard 26 somebody was thrown
around 26 you know so but 12 is 12 good
12 so I didn't see 12 yeah so you know
it's misleading so what what was your
plan with all of this in the beginning
what what inspired all of this and what
what was what what how do you get into
that because you're probably doing what
was your business first or is it Batman
the Joker look like I have a plan yeah
dog chasing chasing a car if I did
caught it I wouldn't know what to do
with it yeah no i mean my i had no plan
i I opened a mortgage company I was a
mortgage broker I was basically I got a
degree in fine arts were you a legit
mortgage broker at any point man I mean
initially I went into it I got my
license I was going to be a mortgage
broker I started being a mortgage broker
I had full intentions of being a
legitimate mortgage broker my very first
loan mm-hmm I go into my managers office
we lay the file down she goes through it
and she pulls out one piece of paper and
sticks it to the side I'm not I don't
really necessarily even know what fraud
is I mean how he would go about
committing fraud I'm just trying to
close loans chief doesn't she goes okay
it's perfect she and I go whoa it she
was well she was you didn't even look at
this did you don't know she's this is a
verification I'm more of rent there vor
right
and I went okay she goes this girl was
thirty days late about eleven months ago
on her rent and I went she said even
noticed that she goes yeah and I oh my
god so I'm thinking right now based on
an underwriting guidelines she doesn't
get alone and and she goes so she pulls
out some wite-out undoes it and she goes
just go ahead and get rid of it make a
copy of it and we'll put it back in the
file you'll be fine
guys no yeah and I went I said well that
that's that's that's fraud right and I
go that that's fraud and she goes keep
in mind keep in mind like Ford Motor Car
is looking for my truck my credit cards
had been shut off
I mean I'm behind on my mortgage I mean
I'm in desperate dire straits so you
know she said look worse that's gonna
happen under I did underwriting catches
it she was and maybe you get fired maybe
they just don't close alone she said
you're nobody's going to jail
and I went you know she said do what you
want to do she's nobody looking for my
car and so I you know so I grabbed it
and I whited it out I made a copy stuck
it in sweated bullets for about five
days five days later boom the loans
ready to close I go down there the girl
signs the paperwork I get a check for
3500 ollars yeah I mean I'm ecstatic
yeah I mean 3500 bucks I'm like 29 years
old that was a ton of money that got me
back on my feet and I stood next thing
you know I'm closing for loans the next
month I'm closing six loans the next
month the next month it's eight then
it's ten and it's 12
they make me a a manager of the brand in
office and then that mortgage company
got shut down it may be six months and
keep in mind to at that point when I
kind of realized what's going on it it
you know it got to the point where you
walked in and it's like all the numbers
work but you only made 45 thousand last
year but if you made fifty five I could
get you alone so I mean especially you
just put fifty five to change the change
the w2 I have a degree in fine arts I
change
thank you I send it in I pray that they
are not going to ask any specifics when
they call to verify the employment keep
in mind the verification of employment
comes to me mmm
I changed that to say 45 or to say 55
just like the w2 it closes and boom the
closes there's a check for three
thousand four thousand dollars at that
point it just seems too easy then right
this is like you're good nobody's in
that industry right so many people were
doing it mmm that was that was pre
financial crisis so that's back in this
is back in like nine 1999 2000 so I'm
like 29 years old and and by the time I
opened up my own mortgage company if you
basically if you walk through the door
with a pulse I'm getting you alone yeah
you got a house I want that you don't
have your down payment I got it we'll
take care of that you know I you know
you you you you wash cars you've never
claimed claim taxes it's not a big deal
it's not a big deal don't worry I got
let's land this loan yeah I pull your
credit it's questionable I can get you
in a house yeah got you Wow
I mean you know just to get them in
there and you know maybe they make a few
payments maybe they make all the
payments right so that's the problem is
that that's a border that right there if
that's a $200,000 loan well that's two
hundred thousand dollars in fraud I only
got a broker fee at that point right but
what happened was very quickly I ended
up with a staff underneath me that were
were just guys doing that so we're all
rehabbing houses were buying houses
anymore see tampa heights were fixing up
houses were selling those houses we're
getting our own people loans and we're
committing you know a massive amount of
mortgage fraud I mean it's on one point
I probably had 14 guys working for me
you know it's always in between like
eight to fourteen and there was really
only like half a dozen of them there
were any any good anyway right you know
and what's funny about is like most of
the guys that worked for me all still
work in real estate like they're all
around really oh yeah so so I'll see
somebody I remember I saw somebody who
was on my my indictment this is when I
was in the halfway house a girl that was
the best broker I'd ever had she was
amazing
and I saw her I was in the halfway house
I was on my way to work
pull in two behind her and Dunkin Donuts
and she looked right at me she looked
right in the mirror she goes she does
this keep in mind she's thinking this
guy's getting out of prison in 2030 so
I'm not supposed to be out of prison so
she does this does one I can see her
she's got the mirror right here and she
goes like this and then she backs up
like she's hiding from me I'm still
staring right at you yeah so I'm looking
at her like you know and I kind of I I
do this to her and she goes and I mean
it's just she never she didn't I thought
she's gonna get out of the car she's
gonna say hey what's up how are you
nothing of course she also is like the
manager of a bank and you certainly
don't want to be associated with a bank
hell no and you're you're also listed on
an indictment that you just were never
prosecuted for oh [ __ ] right so you know
I've got all these people that are
around that are like hey man what's
going on how's it going what's going on
and they all want to hang out and talk
but only to varying degrees
[Laughter]